in the 1920s you know Niels Bohr and
Albert Einstein to Erwin Schrodinger and
Verner Heisenberg could get together in
the same room and talk about these
things 10 years later they're all in
different continents right or different
countries and they can't travel back and
forth and they didn't have the internet
so just the pace of progress was
enormously slowed down the focus of
physicists shifted to very practical
things right building bombs and stuff
like that and then even if they did
weren't practical things like
understanding particle physics in
quantum field theory and all these other
very pressing questions so quantum
mechanics measurement problem kinds of
questions were put on the back burner
and for that matter it's not clear how
to make progress on these questions
right if you have a question about
particle physics you can take two
particles and smash them together and do
the experiment and see what happens it
for the interpretations of quantum
mechanics says as they used to be called
it wasn't clear how you would ever know
what the right answer was I'm joined by
Sean Carroll theoretical physicist
especially in quantum mechanics gravity
and cosmology research professor at the
Department of Physics the California
Institute of Technology and also the man
behind the mindscape podcast Sean
welcome the show thanks very much for
having me super excited to have you on
been a little while since we've delved
into physics on the show so we're gonna
have to get over a little bit of inertia
some audience and my inertia as well and
well we'll kick start everything back
off again right inertia is part of
physics that's okay we understand it you
are the man if there was ever a man to
get over some inertia it's you right
there before we before we even start
talking about physics mindscape podcast
that you it's not been going super long
right but you've had some insane guests
like max tegmark Seth MacFarlane the guy
that had a Family Guy created like the
voice of Brian and Stewie Griffin that's
insya yeah no it's been great it's been
like a year and a half I've been very
very lucky and people saying it not
everyone says yes but you know I always
wanted it to be one one of the things
why I wanted to do the podcast was just
so that I could talk to intelligent
people about things other than physics
and I've gotten some great guests and
all over the spectrum so yeah it's been
fun is that informing the direction of
any sort of more writing that you're
looking at you but you attempted to
branch out into anything after having
these conversations
I've always been tempted you know I've
oh and I always do so you know my
previous book the big picture was very
broad a lot of philosophy a lot of
biology was in there and my last book
was pure physics so the next book is not
gonna be pure physics again I want to
you know keep it keep it mixing it up
okay so tell us about your last book
something deeply hidden why'd you write
it well it's a book about quantum
mechanics and the world does not need
another book about quantum mechanics for
its own sake there's lots of books out
there of varying degrees of usefulness
one of the things I did for the book you
can see the results right in Chapter one
is I went to Amazon and typed in the
word quantum into the search bar and
looked at all of the books that had
quantum in the title quantum healing and
quantum leadership and quantum yoga and
it just goes on and none of them have
the Schrodinger equation or any
differential equations at all in them so
I didn't want to you know just be
negative but I think that a lot of even
the good books on quantum mechanics have
this attitude of saying like quantum
mechanics is really really bizarre it's
mysterious we'll never understand it
look at how bizarre it is and I wanted
to kind of be the opposite I wanted to
kind of say look this is just science
it's perfectly understandable even if we
don't understand it yet there's no
reason to think we can't understand it
and even though I have a favorite way of
understanding it what I really care
about is the fact that it can be
understood what does it mean for
something to not be understood but be
understandable well you know we think
that there's plenty of puzzles in
science right there are things we don't
yet know we don't know exactly how the
moon came to be right was it something
colliding with the earth or was it sort
of the mutual formation of the moon the
earth at the same time but no one thinks
this is impossible to understand right
we'll get there it's just a matter of
you know getting the evidence and doing
the theory etcetera
I think that quantum mechanics has this
weird unique status where it was put
together in the 1920s with sort of a
wall around it saying don't ask
questions about the deep things going on
here the way I like to say it is
physicists are extremely good at using
quantum mechanics without understanding
it it's exactly like I'm good at using
my smartphone to send text messages or
take pictures but I couldn't build one
right and that's how quantum mechanics
is for physicists and I don't think that
it needs to be and I think this is a
huge huge wrong turn that physics took
and we're trying to sort of correct the
course right about now hmm so what what
is it about quantum mechanics that makes
it so slippery it's that in the rules
that we developed in the 1920s and we
still teach to our undergraduates today
quantum mechanics is unique in the
following way there's a set of rules for
what physical systems are and how they
evolve just like every other theory of
physics when you're not looking at them
and then there's another set of rules
that apply when you look at something
when you measure it when you observe it
and no other theory of physics has
anything like that I mean there's
general relativity Maxwell's equations
for electromagnetism Newtonian mechanics
like there's no set of rules that say
what you see and what happens to a
system when you measure it and so why
does quantum mechanics seem to need
these extra rules and this is what's
called the measurement problem of
quantum mechanics and it's just been
hanging around unanswered since the
1920s could you break down the
measurement problem could you explain it
with some experimental examples sure you
know what we teach our students is that
if you take an electron for example
right you imagine the standard picture
of an atom that we've all seen that has
a little nucleus at the center and
electrons are orbiting around it so we
know that can't be right because
electrons orbiting like that would give
off light would lose energy would spiral
in and all atoms would collapse into a
point if that picture were correct okay
so they came up with the idea well maybe
the electron is not a particle maybe
it's a wave maybe it's spread out and
the wave sort of has a minimum
wavelength just like when you pluck a
violin string or something like that
there's different allowed wavelengths
and that's why the electron can't
collapse because it's actually spread
out that's a great idea then we have an
equation the Schrodinger equation given
to us by Erwin Schrodinger which says
how the electron behaves etc except that
when we look at the electron when we
shoot an electron through a detector it
doesn't look like a big fuzzy wave like
you know an electromagnetic wave would
look like it looks like there's a track
like there's a trajectory like it's a
particle like it's located somewhere so
that seems to imply just from on the one
hand we need the electron to be a wave
so that atoms don't collapse from the
other hand when we look at it it looks
like a particle that we need to separate
sets of rules and in what's called the
Copenhagen interpretation the standard
interpretation of quantum mechanics put
together in the 1920s they sort of just
leaned into that they said yes there's a
separate set of rules for what happens
when you measure a quantum system but
what they didn't do is tell you what it
means to measure a quantum system like
does it have to be a person could it be
a video camera could it be a cat you
know yeah yeah how quickly does it
happen what if I just glanced at it and
don't measure it very accurately does
that count corner of my eye yeah yeah
and you know what we teach our students
is that when you measure the system its
wavefunction dramatically changes it
collapses as we say it was all spread
out and then it collapses to being at
one point that's where you see it and it
you can't even predict where it's going
to collapse to you can only say the
probability of getting different
measurement outcomes so the questions of
you know what counts as a measurement
when does it happen how quickly does it
happen why is it a probability rather
than a definite outcome
all of these are bundled together and
what you call the measurement problem of
quantum mechanics how much of that is an
experimental Liszt's problem and how
much of that is a theoretician problem
zero of it is an experimentalist problem
I mean experimentalists have done the
experiments you know I mean it was an
experimentalist problem in 1920s
those experiments have been done there's
extra experiments to be done but the
fact that when we look at the quantum
systems they behave differently than we
don't look at them it's not because the
experiments aren't very good the
experiments are following it's because
the theoretical prediction is wildly at
odds with what you observe if you don't
think hard about what's going on so
there's no in your view is there any
more work to be done from the
theoreticians at this point or is it
that the sorry from the experimentalist
at this point or is it that the
theoreticians kind of need to get the
chalk on the blackboard and and do yeah
I would say the theorists are way behind
right now because they stopped thinking
about this in the 1930s you know people
like Einstein and Schrodinger so not
exactly lightweights in the history of
physics they were outraged by the state
of quantum mechanics they're like we're
not done come on obviously we need to
think harder we need to do better than
what we have now but people like Niels
Bohr and Berner Heisenberg and their
friends said oh no no no we're basically
done let's put this to work and you know
do particle physics and do nuclear
physics and do condensed matter physics
and so forth and as a result for
whatever reasons you can there's a long
list of reasons that's interesting topic
to talk about the physics community went
on the side of Bohr and Heisenberg
against Einstein in Schrodinger and they
said let's just not think about this
very hard and they said this very
explicitly like when people started to
try to think about it they got kicked
out or ignored or abandoned or whatever
so I would say yeah as a theorists are
way behind right now we're just not
anywhere near where we should be in
terms of thinking through things like
you know what counts as a measurement
they're different ways to experimentally
distinguish different theories how do
you get the classical world of the
quantum world all these questions it's
not one of the reasons that there is a
discrimination towards the classical
world that the real world applications
appear to be the the classical world is
emerging out of the quantum world we
know enough to then be able to build a
rocket or make a building work or create
an iPhone and it's that well we'll look
at that what at some point in the future
is that why well a lot of it is you know
the story that we were told back in the
1920s is you're an observer the thing
you're observing quantum mechanically is
that particle okay or maybe a couple of
particles an atom or an electron or
something like that a photon and your
bag and the particles small and forget
about in between like you're so big
compared to the particle that you're
basically classical right so you can
have a classical observer according to
this story which i think is a bad story
but this is what we tell ourselves the
observer can be treated classically the
system that they're looking at is
treated quantum mechanically and you can
get away with that as long as you were
you know in the 20s or 30s and just
observing particles these days where our
technology is moving forward to the
extent where we can create quantum
mechanical effects in much bigger
systems so the dividing line between
quantum and classical is not nearly as
clear as it used to be and so that's
part of what I mean if you want to build
a quantum computer for example or all
these other quantum technologies you
actually have to take quantum mechanics
seriously in a way that you didn't have
to if all you want to do is bump two
particles into each other and see what
happened at the end of the day hmm
why does quantum mechanics become
classical mechanics is there a line I
would like to know this question so
there's a whole nother long you know you
don't get me started it's what I want to
say um we are so bad at quantum
mechanics that one of the ways that
we're bad is that we take the classical
world for granted so the classical world
just to be clear is the world that
you're used to right there are tables
and chairs and baseballs and soccer
balls and they move in trajectories and
you can look at them and see where they
are what you need to know is where they
are and how fast they're moving and you
can predict everything else from that
the quantum world as we learned to
describe it in the 1920s is a completely
different place you know there are no
positions or velocities that's just not
it's not like we don't know what they
are that's not what exists what exists
is this wave of entangled particles all
throughout the universe it's an entirely
different way of talking and you might
think that there is this huge
Challenge of starting with this abstract
wave that quantum mechanics talks about
and explaining how it becomes to look
like a classical world with baseballs
and tables and stuff like that but
basically we cheat you say like well we
know that the world does look classical
at the end of the day so we're gonna put
in that answer into all of our analysis
I'm going to treat me and the planets as
classical and not worry about anything
until we get down to elementary
particles so this question of how you go
from just a purely quantum description
to the classical world I have opinions
about it but it's one of the things we
haven't explored as theorists nearly as
well as we should some of the very basic
questions are completely unanswered to
the current state of the art it's like
you know when you go to a theme park and
it's you must be this tall to ride the
ride it's like you must be this big to
be classical mechanics like what yeah oh
is it strange again coming from someone
who has no idea about physics to me it
would seem natural for physics to be
constant for there to be rules and laws
that govern everything and for there to
not be some sort of resolution at which
if you look below that in terms of how
closely you look at something that those
laws change is that surprising well I
think it's not I think it's not the
situation we're really faced with it's
quantum mechanics it's not something
that becomes true when you look at small
systems that is what we were telling
ourselves back in 1920s but again that's
kind of nonsense quantum mechanics is
true at all scales you and I are
perfectly quantum mechanical and there's
a limit where things become big enough
that you don't need quantum mechanics to
describe what's going on there's a good
approximation given to us by classical
mechanics so it's not that it would be
indeed very very weird if the rules of
nature were different for big things and
small things and I'm sure we'll get to
at some point in the conversation the
many-worlds formulation of quantum
mechanics which was invented by Hugh
Everett was a graduate student in the
50s and this is exactly one of the
things that he complained about you
was writing letters to niels bohr
etcetera saying why in the world can you
treat the observer is classical you know
we're made of atoms and things like that
we're made of things that obey the laws
of quantum mechanics why don't we we
should take that seriously and that's
exactly what he showed how we could do
so just before we get on to that I'm
right in thinking that there was a few
people in your book that you quote as
having been dissuaded from working on
quantum mechanics yourself included
right could you tell us some stories
about that Adam Sabina Hassan Felder on
talking about politics in physics and
for the listeners who didn't catch that
episode it it's a while ago it's back in
the 30s I think with a number 30 not in
the nineteen thirty not the 1930s and I
totally didn't understand just how
political and subject to social bias and
reputation and you know all of that
stuff that the world of physics was and
the synopsis that Sabina sort of came up
with she finished was well if nothing
else today you have learned the
politicians appeared they're physicists
are people too and I was like yeah yeah
so could you talk us through some of the
that saw the politics of quantum physics
yeah you know physicists are people too
and there's a lot of politics and
reputation all that stuff is very true I
don't like to use the word politics in
this context because as ramifications
like it has connotations elsewhere and
furthermore you know it's very hard to
get this right because especially in
theoretical physics where we're saying
well we know that our current theories
are pretty good but not perfect we want
to get to better theories everyone has a
different opinion about which theory
might be better we don't know the right
answer yet and so if someone's best
favorite theory is not the one that is
accepted by other people they're gonna
say yeah those people just don't
appreciate you know a theory they're
just being political and driven by you
know groupthink and whatever
and maybe that's true or maybe your
theories just not as good so it's I'm
literally I'm not saying that
rhetorically maybe your theory is better
maybe it's not that's very very hard to
pick that out in an unbiased way
especially in a situation like we're in
right now or like we have been in
quantum mechanics for many decades when
the experiments don't clearly
distinguish between one way of doing
things and another way so putting aside
like politics and bias and stuff like
that it's certainly true that the course
of physics is heavily influenced by
influential people right it's you know
someone who is a brand-new graduate
student and has a good idea an idea that
is not in accord with the prevailing
standards of the field is gonna have a
much harder time than a famous Nobel
Prize winner who everyone respects and
that's not crazy because there are a lot
more people who are young graduate
students who have really bad ideas it's
not just just by being unknown doesn't
make you right
so there's a filter you know physicists
have a way of dealing with new ideas and
just like everyone else in the world
they're like they take pay attention to
different ideas depending on where
they're coming from and how plausible
they sound and how well articulated they
are and so forth okay having said all of
that I do think that there as I said
there was this massive abandonment of
the right set of questions to ask in the
whole 20th century by physicists and
part of it was so there's so many
different things going on part of it was
just world war to happen right I mean
think about when this is and think about
who it was a lot of these smart people
were Germans a lot of them were Jewish
so in the 1920s you know Niels Bohr and
Albert Einstein Erwin Schrodinger and
Verner Heisenberg could get together in
the same room and talk about these
things ten years later they're all in
different continents right or different
countries and they can't travel back and
forth and they didn't have the internet
so just the pace of progress was
enormously slowed down the focus of
physicists shifted to very practical
things right
building bombs and stuff like that and
then even if they did weren't practical
things like understanding particle
physics in quantum field theory and all
these other very pressing questions so
quantum mechanics measurement problem
kinds of questions were put on the
backburner and for that matter it's not
clear how to make progress on these
questions right if you have a question
about particle physics you can take two
particles and smash them together and do
the experiment and see what happens it
for the interpretations of quantum
mechanics says as they used to be called
it wasn't clear how you would ever know
what the right answer was and borrowed
barriers to entry quite high well it's
the the state of the art was so bad that
the ideas that were being thrown around
did sound more like literary
interpretations than good old physical
theories the state of the art has gotten
a lot better now we're actually talking
about real distinct well-defined
rigorous physical theories that we can
distinguish between but in the 40s and
50s that just wasn't the case it's a
shame it's as it seems to me as
surprised as well that Einstein's side
of the fence didn't win yeah exactly so
that is a surprise you might think that
Einstein didn't like the you know the
the Deontay Wilder of the big
heavyweight champion of the world when
it comes to light directing the physics
community but he was also kind of a
loner right he didn't collaborate a lot
he didn't have students very much he
moved to the Institute for Advanced
Study in Princeton where he didn't teach
classes where someone like Niels Bohr
was endlessly gregarious worked with
everyone had an institute of his own
where he invited everyone to hang out
and so forth and would badger them and
hecta them into doing things so there's
a personality this I think this goes to
Sabinas point there just the fact that
Niels Bohr and Albert Einstein were very
different personalities affected the
course of physics and it became so bad
that you know at some point the major
journal within the physics community
just stopped looking at papers on the
foundations of quantum mechanics David
Bohm who was one of the best people
working on this
stuff was hounded by the house on
American Activities community committee
for being a communist in the 1950s and
was eventually he had to flee to Brazil
I mean he has letters of recommendation
from Einstein and Oppenheimer and he
couldn't get a job in the United States
right John Bell who was a brilliant
theorist who worked at CERN was a
particle physicist by day and worked on
the foundations of quantum mechanics at
night and didn't tell anyone
nextdoor office didn't know that's what
he was doing and now his theorem is very
famous and we all know about it even
today tell the story in my book you know
I do a bunch of different things some
fine ocean foundations of quantum
mechanics some gravity and particle
physics and stuff like that and I'm told
that when we're doing our grant renewals
don't talk about quantum mechanics talk
about cosmology or gravity that's the
serious stuff that's what's gonna get us
funded that's the sexy stuff it's
interesting you got you've got someone
like Albert Einstein that still needs to
play the game I think I was having a
discussion yesterday with with someone
on Instagram live and we were talking
about exactly that he can have the most
virtuous beautiful message in the world
which is full of integrity and adding
value but you still got to play the game
to some degree and you know if Albert
Einstein perhaps fell afoul of that a
little bit and he's you know one of the
if not the best-known physicist of all
time I think there's there's probably a
lesson to be learned I don't know it's a
probably a difficult pill to swallow
isn't it someone who's got so much
talent and and and had raw ability and
understanding with like was just not
playing a social game correctly it's a
interesting really interesting point
it's a it's part of it and the other
part is you know Einstein had a vision
for what the theory should be like right
and he could say over and over again I
think the theory should be like this but
he never actually came up with a theory
that was like this and in fact this
famous theorem of John Bell Bell's
Theorem that we now think is famous
basically says that what Einstein was
trying to go for is impossible to get
so you know Einstein could Hector his
colleagues in the community but he
didn't offer any useful alternative at
the time so the alternatives that we're
faced with now are all crazy from
Einsteins point of view they either
involved nonlocality with spooky action
at a distance were you know branching
into multiple worlds or dramatic
unpredictability or something that
Einstein would not have liked and so you
know I think that's if he had come up
with a killer theory that would replace
the conventional wisdom things might
have been very different was he working
on that before he passed you know if
that was part of the work that was
unfinished well I think you know he I
don't think that was a major focus of
his but you know he did in 1935
published a famous paper called the EPR
paper Einstein Podolsky and Rosen where
he basically emphasized the importance
of what we now call quantum entanglement
and I think it was hurting her hurting
her and Einstein wrote letters back and
forth all the time because they were on
the same side and Einstein you know
helped Schrodinger come up with
Schrodinger's cat example and
Schrodinger gave the word entanglement
to Einstein's theoretical prediction but
it wasn't an alternative theory it was
just saying you know here's the
craziness of quantum mechanics you can't
possibly believe this something that was
also furnitures point was Schrodinger's
cat it wasn't like wow look at how crazy
quantum mechanics is this like you can't
possibly believe this can you and the
answer tends to be yeah we should
believe it so we've touched on three
different things that I've got in my
notes that I want to talk about one of
them being how spooky and how the
uncertainty within quantum theory allows
spookiness and spirituality to be kind
of crowbarred in another one of them is
the many-worlds yep so let's why do we
want to go first let's do what what do
you think many worlds or should we
should we work on the spookiness well
let me explain entanglement a little
because that'll help us understand many
worlds and again this is Einsteins point
in his 1935 paper so I like to describe
it using a the Higgs boson which
Einstein didn't know anything about
right so elementary particles like
electrons and Higgs bosons and photons
can spin and they have a feature that
they're always spinning by the same
amount they don't speed up or slow down
but an electron for example can spin
clockwise or counter clockwise the Higgs
boson doesn't spin at all
it's spinless spin zero so the Higgs
boson can decay it can you know in fact
it does decay very very quickly into
let's say an electron and a positron
positron is the anti electron and we
know the total amount of spin in the
universe is constant it's not being
created or destroyed angular momentum
it's not being created or destroyed so
how in the world can a spin zero
particle decay into two particles that
have spin the answer is they better be
spinning in opposite directions so it
cancels out okay yes yes and that's that
makes perfect sense
sorry projector how do you know it's
yeah spin zero I'm sorry how did you
know that the total amount of spin in
the universe is the same Oh how do you
know it's the same I mean it's a it's
one of the famous conservation laws of
physics so energy is conserved momentum
is conserved angular momentum is also
conserved and spin is a form of angular
momentum even down at the quantum level
there's no special rule down there nope
there's no special rule down there it's
a this it's an absolute you know quantum
mechanics doesn't say anything goes it
doesn't say anything can happen or even
everything as a probability of happening
there are some things that just don't
happen in quantum mechanics or do you
happen all of them there's also things
that do happen but you know there's some
things that don't happen so a spit zero
particle converting into a spin 1/2
particle is not ever gonna happen
no he's just okay so when so it's so the
Higgs splits into two particles an
electron and a positron oh sorry that's
my phone that's an i well you know it's
a tune yeah modeski Martin would for
anyone interested out there in podcast
land so we say the electron can be spin
up or spin down and quantum mechanics
says that the in fact when you haven't
yet looked at it the wave the wave
function as we say at the electron
there's a superposition of spin down and
spin up it's neither one or the other
it's some combination of both so there
can be
for example if it's an even
superposition there's a 50/50 chance of
observing it spin up or observing it
spin down likewise for the positron
going the other way can be spin down or
spin up and can be a 50/50 chance and
what you know is they're oppositely
oriented so their total spins add up to
zero but you don't know whether it's
electron up and positron down or
electron and positron up or in fact what
it will be is some superposition of both
so that's right there that's
entanglement because it's saying that I
don't know whether the electron is up or
down when I measure it but I know that
if I measure it the positron will be the
opposite mm-hmm-hmm and what this is
telling you is that in quantum mechanics
you don't have a quantum state a
wavefunction for the electron and then
separately have a quantum state a wave
function for the positron you have one
wave function for both at the same time
it says there's a probability that one
is up one is down is probability that
one is down one is up and there's no
probability they're both in the same way
could then not be the case that one is
up and one is down it's not a case of
them being either way and when you
observe it just happens to be that it
could be but the quantum mechanics makes
a prediction right it makes a prediction
for when you see the particles come out
of Higgs boson decay there be 50 50 up
and down for the electron 50 50 up and
down for the positron okay so it's not a
case that it is one of those two and you
just look at it and it is the one that
it is it's a case that it could be
either of them and the observation
causes it to choose well you know this
is exactly the question that Einstein
was worrying about you know so so he
makes the point that I can make these
two particles he was using different
examples but the underlying point is the
same I could take one of them and just
let it fly off to another star system
light-years away right and then I could
measure my particle here and the
entanglement doesn't fade away or get
less and less as the particles become
separated so if you take quantum
mechanics seriously says Einstein you're
telling me that when I measure my
particle here to be spin up or spin down
instantly light-years away the other
particle changes to be oppositely
oriented that's his spooky action at a
distance that's what he's like how does
it know for light-years away at alpha
centauri that i just measured the spin
right here and he's like yet again you
know this is his thing is surely you
don't believe that's so he thinks
Einstein is convinced that there was
some fact of the matter about when you
were gonna measure this electron we're
gonna get spin up or spin down and
therefore this in fact of the matter for
the other 1/2 that there's something
something deeply hidden right that would
predict with a hundred percent
probability what you're going to
eventually observe and what john bell
proved is that that can't happen unless
there's some other kind of spooky action
at a distance all along so the spooky
action at a distance is just absolutely
part of quantum mechanics like it or not
hmm am i right in thinking as well that
that the measurement of one versus
another that was four light years away
would happen instantaneously so that
would be the idea yeah that's decimation
which also would I mean does that break
the maximum speed of something is it
actually a speed that some things happen
at the same time that's a great question
you know it's a the answer seems to be
that it violates the spirit this might
be true but it's unfair and we really
shouldn't sanction it so when the thing
is when you measure the particle here
you know that if you get spin up that's
gonna be spin down if you get spin down
that's gonna be spin up so the state the
way that we describe the particle over
there does change instantly right away
outside of your life right outside of
your light cone faster than the speed of
light the thing is the person over there
doesn't know what answer you got until
as far as they're concerned it's still
50/50 so you can't actually use it to
send any information
this the speed limit the speed of light
sir well you know Weinstein invented
that so of course he was very offended
so it's like yeah that the quantum
mechanics was somehow sneaking around
the law somehow he didn't like that at
all yeah that is funny okay so we've got
entanglement
yeah and now let's go many-worlds good
so whoever in the 1950s looks upon
quantum mechanics and just says oh my
god this is this is not good enough and
he says basically what you folks you've
forgotten two things one is the observer
as we've already said it's a quantum
mechanical system themselves so they're
not really classical so when you observe
let's say when you observe at a single
electron right what does it mean to do
an observation well if the electron has
a wave function and can be in a
superposition of different things then
in principle you can have a wave
function too and you could be in a
superposition and the other thing that
he says everyone for God is entanglement
so not only can you have your own wave
function but in fact really there's one
wave function that describes you and the
electron at the same time and he says
forget about all these dumb rules about
measurement and observation what if we
didn't have those rules what if we just
had the equation the Schrodinger
equation which says what happens when
you the quantum system that is you
interacts with the electron that's in a
superposition of spin up and spin down
and he says the answer is 100% perfectly
clear you and the electron evolve into
an entangled superposition where there's
one part of the entanglement which says
the electron was spin up and I observed
it to be spin up and there's another
part of the entanglement which says the
electron was spin down I observed it to
be spin down and everyone agrees that
that's what Schrodinger's equation
predicts that's the nice thing about
having equations they predict things and
they're not really up for debate that's
that's what it predicts but where they
are upset is nobody in history has ever
said you know I observe that electron
and now I feel like I'm in a super
position having observed its spin-up and
spin-down and ever it says I know why
because there are now two copies of you
there's one copy that observed it spin
up and one copy that observed its spin
down and what happens to one of these
copies of you will not a factor be
influenced by or interact with the other
copy ever again they go their own ways
it's as if they are separate worlds so
the many-worlds interpretation of
quantum mechanics did not come about
because whoever it said what quantum
mechanics needs is an infinite number of
extra world it came about because he
said what quantum mechanics needs is
getting rid of all these dumb rules
about measurement and probability and
collapse just take seriously what the
equations are trying to tell you and it
says that you will branch into separate
worlds and all you have to do is deal
with it if you're willing to deal with
it all of your problems go away if you
in other words if you think that an
electron can be in a superposition of
spin up and spin down then you should be
able to believe that you can be in a
superposition and you should be able to
believe that the universe can be in a
superposition of all different things
and if you treat those different parts
of the superposition as different worlds
you solve all the problems of quantum
mechanics when you say interact with or
observe the electron what does that mean
does that mean how high ever fidelity
are we looking at this is it every
Planck length amount of time that
happens of every single movement and
every single potential movement how does
that work do you know I mean ya know
it's a very specific criterion when a
quantum mechanical system that is in a
superposition of different possibilities
becomes entangled with the wider outside
world the wave function branches so
there's an electron sitting in every
atom in your body right now but mostly
they're not becoming entangled with
anything they're just staying in their
atoms right that's just what they're
doing but when you take an electron and
remove it from an atom and then send it
through a magnetic field
it'll be deflected one way if it's been
up be deflected another way if it's been
down and then
you let it hit a screen and you observe
a dot either there or there and that
process observe a dot okay
it angers the electron with the wider
world because there's now a dot on the
screen okay and that's world branches so
it only happens during specific sorts of
experiments or is this happening when I
sit down on my chair it happens when
quantum systems become entangled with
the outside world so it's happening all
the time in your body right now because
there there's a certain number of
radioactive nuclei in your body there's
about five thousand radioactive decays
per second in a typical human body and
so though that radioactive decay means
that some nucleus emitted a particle and
that particle bumped into things and
became entangled with the outside world
so five thousand times a second we're
actually much more than that but at
least that many times you're branching
the wave function just by sitting there
in your chair multiplied by however many
particles there are in the universe that
are also actually doing this yes per
second again most you know like a
typical photon or whatever just spreads
out throughout the universe it doesn't
become entangled anything until it hits
a telescope or a planet or something
like that so you know radioactive
elements are rare you know in the
universe so particles can become can go
a long way without being entangled with
anything
but they often are also so both things
are happening yet how how is that two
worlds that exist at the same time how
does it how do I not just see another
chair or another atom or like there be
an extra little bit on the edge of the
chair what's going on that well because
they have truly become separate and this
is the process which in quantum
mechanics we call decoherence think of I
like to think of Schrodinger's cat right
so in short Agurs cat there's the box
and there's a quantum event which with
50/50 probability either in
Schrodinger's telling either kills the
cat or keeps it alive and in my book I
made it put the cat to sleep or let it
stay awake because it can just be
sleeping gas you have no reason to kill
the cat but the point is that in the
conventional telling the cat is
literally neither awake or asleep it is
it a superposition of both on
till you open the box and you observe it
and again Schrodinger is saying surely
you don't believe that surely you don't
believe that the state of the cat
dramatically changed so here's what
modern Everette Ian's would say if the
cast asleep lying on the floor of the
box versus being awake gets up and
walking around trying to get out of the
box all of the stuff in the box all the
air molecules all the photons of light
and so forth may or may not bump into
the cat depending on whether it's lying
on the floor or walking around so what
that means is that these two different
parts of the wavefunction of the cat
awake and asleep interact with the
environment around it in different ways
and that means the cat becomes entangled
with the environment around it like it
or not so the universe branches into two
different copies long before you open
the box hmm
to get to the answer to your question
because there's so many photons hitting
the cat or not hitting it and because
you know one will get absorbed if it
hits the cat or just go right on by if
it doesn't those two parts of the wave
function of the universe cat awake and
cat asleep become completely separated
from each other so you if it's you in
one branch with the cat awake you can't
see any result from the branch of the
wavefunction where the cat is asleep the
particles in that branch of the wave
function just don't interact with you
they're there perpendicular to you
literally in the space of all possible
wave functions it's so challenging to
wrap your head around for someone I
recommend buying my book solution linked
in the show notes below ladies and
gentlemen follow it through this I you
know we're trying to use and this must
be I don't know whether it's challenging
for you or whether it adds or removes
difficult if you but throughout this
conversation you're having to use
classical systems as analogies to
describe the quantum systems you're
talking about plucking a violin string
or you know all of these things it's so
funny and interesting that we have to
analogize
classical physics to describe the
quantum world isn't it yeah it is but
you know what we're people that's okay
like you know people eat there's there's
two levels of this one is of course as
we're having this conversation I'm not
just gonna write down the equations and
point at them and see you say any
questions right you know we're going to
talk about analogies and metaphors and
pictures and visualizations and things
like that and that's very natural and in
some sense it's an important part of
doing science because we have you know
what will the Wilfrid Sellars called the
manifest image of the world the view
that we all carry around that there are
people and planets and you know cats and
dogs and purposes and motions and things
like that and then we have the
scientific image of the world which is
the better and better view of what's
going on given to us by science and we
have to match them somehow
right we have to say like what part of
the everyday world maps on to this part
of the formalism that we're talking
about so all that's you know well and
good for doing science that's it's
inevitable the other level which is a
little bit more problematic is that even
the world's best professional physicists
still kind of think classically and what
that means is usually when we invent a
new quantum mechanical theory to explain
some particles or you know quantum
gravity or something like that we start
with a classical system and we quantize
it there's a whole procedure that you
can look up in textbooks called how to
quantize classical physics and I think
that leads us down a bad road because
the world doesn't work that way the
world doesn't start classically and then
quantize things well just is quantum and
classical physics is a good limit a good
limiting case of approximation that's
valid in certain circumstances so
thinking about it that way is a little
bit of shift of perspective which I
personally think is going to be
extremely important when it comes to
solving some of the more difficult
questions that were faced with in modern
physics okay so moving on to the spooky
stuff yeah I'm sure that a lot of the
people that listening and you know you
said yourself you do your Amazon search
she's thinking about what my gonna call
my new book it's all about quantum
quantum yoga on quantum leadership
quantum leadership I bet quantum
accounting I could probably do some
funky quantum accounting but yeah it's
it's used to crowbar all sorts of stuff
in but one of the things is kind of more
spooky spiritual stuff into reality yeah
why do you think that is well I think
there's two things going on one is
wishful thinking right
quantum mechanics seems mysterious and
there's a lot of other things that seem
mysterious so maybe they're related
somehow and you know other theories of
physics are put to bad uses also so it's
just sort of a bit of sloppiness that
people necessary inevitably give into
but the other thing is that physicists
have done a bad job of trying to
understand quantum mechanics and for a
long time it they've made it seem like
the role of a human observer is somehow
crucial to explaining what happens in
quantum mechanics someone measuring
things right someone actually looking at
systems and that lets you insinuate that
somehow you are bringing the world into
existence just by looking at it and that
is very close to saying that you
influence the world that the ways in
which you look at the world and the ways
in which you interact with it can
somehow change the world out there so
you not only do you bring the world into
existence by looking at it but you can
choose what kind of world to bring into
existence now none of that is anything
to do with quantum mechanics that's all
just crazy talk wishful thinking whoo
whoo kind of nonsense but the physicists
should ser Shara part of the blame for
letting people talk that way because
they've not been at all clear about what
quantum mechanics really says people
talk about manifesting realities and and
I think they use the measurement problem
or I think they would call it like the
observer effect or whatever right yeah
to explain that stuff there was another
conversation I was having recently about
online coaches
online fitness and diet and nutrition
coaches and I was asking that these guys
are saying why is the industry filled
with so much kind of misinformation and
so many charlatans and people like that
and they said that it's because of a
lack of obvious causality between what
what happens and then the results on the
other side of it and where you have this
vacuum of a lack of information it just
allows people to just throw speculation
in there right yeah it's like this
sounds like a plausible narrative and
you know if if there is anything that I
hope that the listeners can take away
from today's conversation it is that
plausible narratives are probably not
the world in which quantum physics
operates like it's not because there's
like a good guy in a bad guy there's
like it's not that like the Higgs boson
was like the referee or something like
that that we love to personify these
sorts of stories right because it brings
them on to our level it brings them on
to the level of a social being but
that's not what's happening
yeah no it's absolutely right and as
David Albert who's a philosopher of
physics once said you know when it comes
to trying to understand the deepest
mysteries of nature if they don't make
you uncomfortable you're not doing it
right
you know of course the world is most
fundamental level is something very very
different than we experience in our
everyday lives so this is one of the
things that that is an important
consideration when you compare many
worlds to other possible interpretations
of quantum mechanics many-worlds is the
simplest as the fewest equations the
fewest ideas it generates what you see
in a very natural way but it's very far
away from what we observe right it's so
different in structure and language then
the world of our everyday experience
that it is perfectly legitimate to say I
just don't believe that this very very
simple lean and mean Theory really gets
us to the world we see so other
alternatives to many worlds generally
bring in a lot more extra stuff that is
somehow latching on to the classical
world
that we experience whether it's extra
hidden variables or ways that particles
behave or whatever and it's not crazy to
think that that might be the way to go
that there might be something extra
other than the pure bare-bones formalism
of quantum mechanics that gives us this
classical world we see around us but the
I was for people like me the many-worlds
version is just so simple and so
compelling that it's worth taking that
extra effort to map it on to the world
we see so we actually see it as sort of
a feature not a bug that many worlds is
so alien and so different because that's
what the nature should be like at its
deepest level mm-hmm so when people say
to kind of close the door to hell that
hopefully that is the observer effect in
the measurement problem for you know
people that are reading the secret and
manifesting yeah good good energies and
bad energies and and stuff like that
without observers in the universe would
everything continue just as it is yeah
absolutely I mean not only that but a
theory like many worlds or the the
respectable alternatives to it hidden
variable theories dynamical collapse
theories is a whole bunch of different
alternatives
the word observer plays no role you know
if that's that was a useful
approximation when we didn't understand
quantum mechanics very well well we
talked about now are the actual
equations telling us what's happening
you know when a big system with many
degrees of freedom interacts and becomes
entangled with a small system that's in
a superposition etc so it was just the
bad old days when the idea of observers
or experiences were thought to be in any
way related to quantum mechanics and
that's just being grunting fathered in
well look not everyone agrees right
progress is slow especially when there's
not a killer experiment to show everyone
they must get on the bandwagon so
progress will happen I think and but you
know there's still people out there
trying to make connections between
quantum mechanics and consciousness or
something like that
and those it's it's much less common
than it used to be it's dying out but
there's still some remnants out there
yeah um I remember reading I might have
even heard you say it yourself talking
about how if we knew is if we knew the
position and the velocity of every
particle that we could work time back
infinitely we could work everything had
been in the is that is that correct
classical mechanics that would have been
true this is a famous thought experiment
from pierre-simon Laplace around the
Year 1800 so Isaac Newton gave us the
rules of classical mechanics in the
1600s but it still it took some time
even though classical mechanics we think
of now is pretty trivial compared to
quantum mechanics it still took some
time for it to sink in you know this
idea that left to its own devices an
object will keep moving in a straight
line at a constant velocity is actually
pretty radical when you think about it
no one has ever seen that right you know
everyone see things that you don't push
on them they come to a rest right as
Aristotle would have predicted so it did
take some time for people to catch on
the Newton's way of thinking and Laplace
was one of the first people to really
get it at a deep level in his bones and
he pointed out that Newton gave us a bit
of a set of laws set of laws of motion
equations of motion with the property
that if you tell me the position and
velocity of everything in the universe
and I have infinite calculational
capacity the future and the past of the
universe are now set they are completely
deterministically predicted by those
laws and by that current configuration
of stuff the quantum version of this
depends on whether or not depends on
what your favorite version of quantum
mechanics which we don't agree on so for
many worlds person there is a version of
this which says that the wavefunction of
all the branches all the worlds at once
evolved completely deterministically
so it evolves in the way the Laplace
would have thought so you can wind it
backward or forward but you need more
than just what the world is doing in
your branch right now you need what's
going on in all the branches of all the
different parts of the wave function of
the universe okay so you need a fabric
of computing
you're not gonna get any one of these
things this is purely let's not even
aspire to trying to do it Wow yeah um so
to round up can you tell us what you're
working on at the moment or what's been
sort of occupying your time right now
well this question that we talked about
about you're really taking quantum
mechanics seriously and trying to derive
the classical world from that rather
than putting it in sneaking it in by
hand is really beginning to seem more
and more important to me so I'm working
on that both sort of at the most
fundamental level just saying you know
okay quantum mechanics how do we go from
quantum mechanics to a classical world
at all and then more specifically we had
this long-standing worry about gravity
Einstein explained that gravity is the
curvature of space-time as a sign
Stein's general theory of relativity and
ever since then we've been struggling to
reconcile gravity with quantum mechanics
so my conviction is that one of the
things holding us back has been this
insistence on starting with a classical
theory in quantizing it so you can start
with general relativity and try to
quantize it it doesn't work so now
people start with something like string
theory and try to quantize that I think
that maybe you'll get some insight by
just starting quantum from the start and
if you understand in general how the
classical world can come out of the
quantum world then a classical world
featuring curved space time and gravity
and things like that should hopefully be
part of it how easy is it for you to
describe why quantum theory and gravity
don't agree ah it's not easy but I like
to say there's sort of two different
sets of puzzles and either one of them
alone would probably be enough but
there's two of them one is just that
there's are what we call technical
puzzles right if you take X plus y and X
is a finite number and Y is a finite
number and you add them together and get
an infinite number something has gone
terribly wrong so this happens when you
start with a classical theory and try to
quantize it often things that should be
finite blow up you get infinities and
Richard Fineman and others back in the
50s
one Nobel Prizes showing how to tame
these infinities in quantum field theory
we've not been able to tame them in
general relativity and so that's the
biggest single nice thing about super
string theory is that these infinities
go away okay so there are technical
problems that string theory seems to
help us with it at the cost of raising
an entirely new technical problem namely
that string theory really only makes
sense if space-time is ten dimensional
and we look around and space-time looks
like it's four dimensional three
dimensions of space one dimension of
time so string theorists need to be very
very clever about getting rid or hiding
those extra six dimensions and that's
another technical problem we haven't
quite solved yet there's also the
conceptual problems so when you talk
about electromagnetism or particles
other things that we typically do in
quantum mechanics you can at least say
things like ok I don't know where the
electron is it has a wave function but I
have two particles they're going to come
in they both have their wave functions
they're going to interact when they're
overlapping we're at the same point in
space right that's when two things
overlap that's the principle of locality
that's what Einstein was very very
protective of he wanted locality to be
very very important but here's the thing
in quantum gravity you're going to take
space-time and let it be curved and
you're gonna quantize the whole kit and
kaboodle then just like an electron can
be in a superposition of spin up and
spin down the geometry of space-time
itself should be able to be in a
superposition of all different kinds of
geometries and when that happens you
can't even point to a location in space
and say here because in these different
parts of the superposition in these
different geometries of space-time
there's no way to associate one point in
one space-time with another point in the
same space-time with the different
geometry the idea of a fixed point in
space seems to have no meaningfulness in
quantum gravity so what are we gonna do
about that how are we gonna make sense
of the idea that fields and particles
only interact when they're low
okay at the same place when there's no
such thing as being located in the same
place in quantum gravity so that's a
conceptual problem it's not like things
blew up and we got infinity it's just
like what do you do with this like
what's going on how do we make sense of
this and that's the kind of thing people
are still struggling with to finish up
one thing that I've always been thinking
about is to me again is a total newb to
physics it feels like theories should
reduce down to something that's very
simple I don't know why it just seems
like there should be universal rules
which don't require an awful lot of
complexity to get back to right do you
think that as we roll forward over
several hundred thousand years that we
are going to see these these theories
become more complex or more simple well
I think I'm pretty optimistic that
things will become more simple that's
certainly been the way physics has been
going for a very long time many worlds
is very very simple just like general
relativity is very simple they're both
very alien to us they're not our
everyday experience oh they seem
difficult but no one denies that writing
the theory down is really really simple
it is like the algorithm is very very
short
there's no guarantee that it continues
like that and of course like we said
there's a whole extra work to be done at
mapping these fundamental theories to
the everyday life you know I don't think
that the theory of psychology is ever
going to become simple I think there's
some in electable complexity about a
human being that's not going to go away
but the fundamental laws should be very
simple that might not be true it's an
empirical question we'll have to find
out but I would definitely say that's
the way to bet I hope so
for the listeners who want to find out a
little bit more why should they had
shown I have a website preposterous
universe calm where you can see the
books I've written a bunch of videos and
of course I have my own podcast called
mindscape where I'm talking to all these
cool people not mostly about physics
some physicists do
Picon but you know that today is really
an episode with a philosopher and I've
had musicians and poker players and
biologists and it's a lot been a lot of
fun for me that's awesome
also yeah you're pretty prolific on
Twitter as well right
Twitter yep Sean M Carroll and again
that's that's a link for my homepage but
yeah I really like Twitter it's a it's
it's for better for worse I used to be a
prolific blogger on my website and I
still do that sometimes but it's easier
to get my point across and a quick tweet
and then move on to do real work rather
than write a respectable blog post so
I'm letting the side down but I do try
to say some interesting things on
Twitter yeah I like it I like if you're
a physicist who's able to get his
message across in less than 360
characters or whatever it is I think
yeah you're doing a good job ladies and
gentlemen it's been an absolute pleasure
you know what to do the links to all of
Sean's books plus his website and this
Twitter and everything else will be
linked in the show notes below if you've
got any questions comments or feedback
got me at Chris relax on all social
media leave a comment in the youtube
channel or just hassled Sean on Twitter
and he'll he'll give you replying maybe
if he's maybe online
Sean thank you so much for your time
it's been great thanks very much Chris
[Music]